[Musique]
bonsoir retour en direct après quelques
problèmes techniques bienvenue dans le
journal de la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mercredi 16 septembre voici
les titres de cette édition départ
direction l'espace programmées en
décembre lui vs q7 réalisé par le latmos
sera mise en orbite par la fusée falcon
9 de space x ce nano satellites est en
ce moment en phase finale d'intégration
et de test à l'observatoire versailles
saint quentin en yvelines et nous avons
pu suivre ses préparatifs
les journées européennes du patrimoine
arrive c'est le week-end prochain pour
l'occasion poissy rouvrira sa maison de
fer laissé à l'abandon depuis plusieurs
années la bâtisse atypique datant de
1896 a été entièrement reconstruite et
puis la page consacrée à la législative
partielle dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines premier tour au programme
dimanche 20 septembre
onze candidats sont en lice parmi eux
pyrrhus pour la république en marche il
est notre invité et puis un peu de magie
à la fin de cette édition je vous le
disais avec les 20 ans de la gazette du
sorcier le célèbre journal autour de
l'univers d'harry potter fêter ses 20
ans à thoiry c'était le week-end dernier
[Musique]
dans l'urgence climatique actuel une
équipe de treize chercheurs du latmos a
développé un satellites miniatures
le lancement est prévu depuis la
californie pour la fin de l'année via la
fusée falcon 9 de space x est
l'instrument est pour l'heure en phase
de test à guyancourt les précisions de
justin brasil ubs cus hâte c'est une
mission dédiée à l'étude du climat et
aux relations soleil terre elle devrait
permettre de mesurer les flux au sommet
de l'atmosphère le lancement de ce nano
satellites est prévue en décembre 2020
on travaille avec la société space x et
on utilisera le lanceur falcon nine donc
on va être mis en orbite depuis la base
américaine de vandenberg c'est une base
militaire à peine plus grand qu'un
rubik's cube il contient une dizaine de
cartes électroniques
ce satellite équipé de plusieurs petits
capteurs miniaturisés donc ici vous
pouvez observer le petit carré noir le
petit carré blanc donc ce sont des
petits détecteurs infrarouges
donc ils sont associés à des nano à des
technologies de pointe comme des
nanotubes de carbone à partir d'espèces
et petit détecteur on va pouvoir mesurer
tous les flux pour ce sommet de
l'atmosphère
le nain de cette élite est entré en
phase de test et les essais fonctionnels
sont terminées désormais on entre en
essais d'environnement donc on doit
valider que notre satellite ne va pas
être cassé durant les vibrations pendant
le lancement évidemment donc on a des
essais de vibrations ensuite on va
devoir faire des essais de température
c'est pour vérifier que notre satellite
va tenir à l'environnement thermique en
orbite
il faut savoir que dans l'espace vert
température est de 4 kelvin c'est à dire
moins de 169 degrés celsius
objectif réaliser tous les essais à
guyancourt notamment des tests
thermiques qu'ils vont recréer
l'environnement spatial
on va avoir la cuve dans laquelle le
satellite va être plongée qui va
représenter l'espace et ensuite on a
donc cette plaque là qui va
présenter la terre donc elle va être
chauffée à la température qui représente
la table c'est-à-dire au moins 20 degrés
et ensuite on a cette flaque ci qui va
représenter le soleil et donc elle va
être chaud fait environ 50 degrés au
total l'ue vs q7 représente un budget de
2 millions d'euros
le latmos qui travaille également sur
les planètes du système solaire
notamment venus qui fait l'actualité en
ce moment l avis existe-t-elle sur place
est en tout cas l'hypothèse avancée par
les chercheurs de l'université de
cardiff
interview express au micro de michael et
demi d'euros alors il faut bien voir que
la nouvelle qui a été annoncée c'est la
détection d'un gaz qui s'appelle la
phosphine et qui sur terre est connu
pour être produit par des bactéries
notamment dans des environnements un peu
hostile sans oxygène donc la présence de
vie à ce stade il est beaucoup trop tôt
pour l'affirmer il faut d'abord un
confirmé que ce gaz est bien présent
avec d'autres méthodes parce qu'on est
vraiment au bord de
de ce qu'on peut faire en termes de
techniques de détection et deuxièmement
bien vérifier qu'on peut pas produire ça
gaze autrement que par de la biologie ce
gaz normalement est censé être instable
dans ces deux venus du les conditions
qui règnent et donc si sa présence est
confirmée il va falloir vraiment trouver
une explication pour pouvoir le faire ça
peut être éventuellement des émissions
volcaniques ça peut être des réactions
chimiques au passage des éclairs dans
les décharges dans les orages
ça peut être des choses qu'on imagine
pas encore donc pas vraiment faire
l'inventaire complet avant d'envisager
l'hypothèse biologique dans l'atmosphère
une longue histoire de l'étude de vénus
qui a commencé dès le début des années
2000 avec une sonde européenne qui
s'appelait venus exprès sur lequel une
sont un instrument qui s'appelait spicav
et était fabriqué par le laboratoire
prédécesseur du latmos qui s'appelait à
l'époque le service d'aéronomie est donc
cet instrument fonctionner jusqu'en 2014
lorsque la sonde s'est écrasé sur la
planète vénus à la fin de sa durée de
vie est actuellement il ya plusieurs
projets de missions spatiales vers de
retour vers vénus sur laquelle est moss
est impliqué européenne indienne etc
[Musique]
l'actualité c'est aussi bien sûr cette
crise sanitaire du coronavirus avec un
mot d'ordre porter un masque comme
mesures barrières la france n'est plus
dépendante de la chine pour ses
protections a affirmé le gouvernement
fin août à rambouillet une production de
masques 100 % en france a été lancé et
1000 commandes par semaine qui profitent
directement aux entreprises du
territoire du sud yvelines le reportage
de marie pas neutre à il y à un mois
cette entreprise basée à rambouillet a
commandé quelques milliers de masques
100% français la vingtaine de salariés
les a essayé et les a tout de suite
adopté
c'est agréable à porter et c'est moins
contraignant que les vins il ya moins de
gêne que les autres parce qu'au niveau
du haut niveau de la peau surtout ça
irrite mois le dirigeant mise sur la
qualité et préfèrent payer ces masques
plus cher pour davantage de confort
l'autre intérêt acheter français
c'est évident qu'il faut prendre une
production française moi qui ai moi-même
en plus agriculteurs si je mets pas en
avant la production française ce serait
comme ça sera un peu décevant tout le
matériel utilisé est fabriqué en france
à l'exception de la barre donner pour
faire fonctionner la machine deux
salariés ont été embauchés à l'origine
de cette initiative
l' envie d'aider les proches des
fondateurs travaille dans le milieu
médical n'était pas question de laisser
ces personnes qui nous sont chères au
contact de
du virus sans sens sans chercher à faire
quelque chose on se sentait un peu
démuni de de les voir ainsi il fallait
qu'on réagisse ne va pas ne rien faire
depuis la mise en place de la machine
plus de cent mille masques ont été
vendus pour développer la production
d'autres embauches sont prévues très
prochainement les masques de france sont
désormais vendus au delà de la frontière
illinoise à quelques jours des 37e
journées européennes du patrimoine
découverte de cette bâtisse atypique du
19e siècle la maison de fer s'apprête à
renaître à poissy longtemps abandonné en
ruines le site rouvrira samedi après
deux ans de travaux mélanie poke et
patrice carmouze et patrick jacques de
dixmude
voici aussi à sa dame de fer cette
maison atypique un son nom des matériaux
utilisés pour sa construction 100% métal
bâti en 1896 elle est une résidence
secondaire de georges de koninck et de
son épouse
la maison de fer sort de l'imagination
d'un ingénieur belge
le joseph d'orly c'est un contemporain
de gustave eiffel les à 19 19 cents
l'exposition universelle à l'époque une
maison de fer est installée ici à à
poissy sur les eaux de poissy en face de
l'hôpital et non loin des quartiers
populaires laissée à l'abandon la
structure ne résiste pas à la tempête de
1999 devenu une ruine le chantier est au
coeur d'une association en 2008 puis en
en 2015 la reconstruction est décidée
par l'équipe municipale pour en faire un
lieu culturel
elle est déplacée dans le parc
meissonnier amusé d'exposition
permanente
l'histoire de la maison de faire
l'histoire du patrimoine pisciacais mais
également des expositions éphémères
typiquement mécano vous le verrez nous a
offert l'échelle 1 12e d'une maison de
faire c'est tout simplement exceptionnel
une ouverture au public à l'occasion des
journées européennes du patrimoine
visites guidées animations théâtrales
feu d'artifice et un concert julien
clerc vous contera sa préférence et leur
préférence à eux c'est la magie des fans
de l'univers harry potter se
réunissaient samedi dernier à
l'orangerie du château de thoiry un
rassemblement pour les 20 ans de la
gazette du sorcier le célèbre jeu
on al de la saga décliné en site
internet et nicolas landry et bixente
m'a rien senti steban se sont glissés
parmi les apprentis sorciers en dollars
us les apprentis sorciers sont à la fête
plus de 500 fans de la saga présents
pour célébrer la 20e année du plus
ancien site internet francophones autour
d'harry potter
on raconte l'actualité du monde d'harry
potter des animaux fantastiques les
nouvelles sorties de livres de films les
produits dérivés les parcs mais aussi on
va un peu plus loin on fait des articles
qui analysent l'univers qui le décrivent
qui décortique me dire qu on est parvenu
à rester jusque jusqu'aujourd'hui qu'on
a continué à vivre que le fandom harry
potter est toujours là et que la gazette
est toujours là c'est juste magique
d'une journée en immersion à l'orangerie
du château de thoiry au coeur de
l'univers de la magie
c'est un moyen de s'échapper un peu de
s'imaginer dans le monde
dans un autre monde où la sorcellerie et
est intégré à la vie et et voilà ça nous
permet de rêver aussi
on peut partager des anecdotes des
choses qu'on a lu récemment parce que
l'univers est vaste éventuellement je
vais s'amuser à chercher les
incohérences et puis l'essayer de se
chercher à qui connaît mieux tel ou tel
sujet entre deux conférences étaient
organisés également des rencontres de
quidditch le sport du sorcier et des
duels de sortilèges cd principe assez
simple embardée livre on regarde comment
les gens meurent et on essaye de
prévenir ça donc quelques mouvements des
skis et puis derrière on apprend les
mouvements basiques de baguettes une
journée dans un autre monde pour les
fans à conserver précieusement dans une
piscine
et pour terminer ce journal vous en avez
l'habitude depuis quelques jours la page
dédiée à la législative partielle dans
la 11e circonscription des yvelines
onze candidats sont sur la ligne de
départ vous voyez leur nom s'afficher un
scrutin rendu nécessaire après la
démission de nadia qui est entrée au
gouvernement
elle est devenue ministre délégué à la
ville premier tour le dimanche 20
septembre c'est dimanche prochain un
éventuel deuxième tour et dimanche 27
septembre et pire lucette avec moi en
plateau bonsoir en soit vous êtes le
référent de la république en marche dans
les yvelines et vous avez été investi
par votre parti pour être le candidat de
la majorité présidentielle dans cette
11e circonscription je précise que c'est
votre premier scrutin en tant que
candidat où vous étiez déjà dans la
république en marche depuis 2016 vont
militer au sein du parti depuis 2016 du
coup pourquoi devenir candidat cette
fois ci pourquoi porter cette
candidature
c'est la suite logique de mon engagement
à la fois en termes de politique
nationale où j'ai suivi avec attention
ce qui se passait depuis 2017 et aussi
de mon engagement local puisque c'est la
11ème circonscription que j'ai commencé
j'ai fait mes débuts politiques en 2016
alors c'est une circonscription sous la
bannière de la république en marche
depuis 2010 est avec aujourd'hui tout de
même un contexte différent il n'y a plus
cette vague en marche que l'on avait
observé en 2010 est la cote du président
de la république n'est pas aussi
forcément au plus haut est ce que votre
parti a les moyens aujourd'hui de
conserver cette 11e circonscription
oui ou c'est quand on discute avec les
habitants quand on fait du porte à porte
ou quand on les rencontre sur les
marques et on se rend compte qu'en fait
sont assez attentifs en fait à la
politique qui a été qui a été mis en
place depuis 2006 17
ils la soutiennent ils sont conscients
des difficultés qu'on rencontre et ils
savent à qui les attribue et ils savent
que le président applique le
gouvernement veut pas être tenu
responsable de tous les problèmes et ils
reconnaissent les efforts qui sont faits
depuis 2007 alors c'est une
circonscription où nadia était député
depuis 2010 est elle a démissioné
puisqu'elle est entrée au gouvernement
son suppléant ou sahwa a été empêchée
puisqu'il est en ce moment visé par une
enquête pour trafic de drogue
international
quel regard vous portez sur ces trois
ans passé par nadia dans cette
circonscription cette 11e
circonscription
écoutez je pense que ça si tu es sont
aujourd'hui parlent d'elles mêmes elle a
fait un travail très très poussées sur
la politique de la ville que ce soit au
niveau national à l'assemblée et au
niveau local où on peut voir que
beaucoup de projets et de dispositifs
nationaux ont pu être appliquée
notamment notamment à traves
dédoublement des classes
je pense aussi aux sites et éducatives
ou au programme action coeur de ville
qui en bénéficiaient à sa construction
on a reçu plusieurs candidats sur ce
plateau qui nous disait ne pas avoir vu
la députée pendant ces trois ans de
fonction qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ceux qui disent qu'ils avaient qu'elle
était absente pendant ces trois ans
c'est un peu facile en fait il ya une
ombre qui ne voit jamais son député 1 en
ronde qui ne peut pas le citer je pense
qu'il faut faut élever un peu le débat
et voir quel a été le bénéfice pour la
circonscription et ne pas se demander si
un tel modèle de vue lorsque vous avez
annoncé votre candidature en juillet
dans le reportage qui était qui avaient
été diffusés sur tv 70,2 vous disiez
être avant tout un homme de terrain
c'est ça que vous voulez mettre en avant
aujourd'hui c'est la priorité pour vous
c'était d'être cet homme de terrain
écoutez il tient à coeur de défendre un
projet que je sais juste parce que je
vis au quotidien la même chose que la
majorité des français
je vais travailler le matin je prends le
train je reste un professionnel de la
politique supérieure en informatique
exactement le style ingénieurs pas un
énarque n'ai pas fait d'études en
sciences politiques n'est pas de
je les défends pas une idéologie que
qu'on m'a appris je défends une
amélioration de la vie quotidienne des
français que défend l' envie de redonner
un peu foi en l'avenir pour pour nos
enfants pour nos anciens parce que au
quotidien j'ai besoin d'eux
de ça et donc j'ai envie de transmettre
cette foi en l'avenir que je me sens
meilleur grâce au programme que je
défends les sujets forts qu'il faudra
porter à l'assemblée nationale on pense
forcément à cette crise sanitaire est ce
qu'il y en a d'autres ont cette rentrée
parlementaire
en cette rentrée parlementaire
évidemment l'actualité va être très
clair jacques le plan de relance qui va
être intégrée dans le projet de loi de
finances qui va débattu d'ici la fin de
l'année
il ya évidemment aussi d'autres sujets
qui me tiennent à coeur
je pense notamment une proposition doit
sur l'inclusion par l'insertion par de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
pardon et qui va notamment permettre
d'étendre les territoires 0 chômeurs de
longue durée et aussi le projet le
projet de loi sur la simplification
administrative qui va paraître en fait à
tout le monde de bénéficier de
procédures plus plus rapide plus simple
on est toujours un peu désespéré convoi
en france la longueur de certaines
procédures
je pense notamment on a parlé de
l'actualité très récente des difficultés
pour faire évacuer les squatteurs de son
domicile
ça sera beaucoup plus rapide maintenant
puisque le préfet pourra en 24 heures
faire évacuer n'importe quel résidence
secondaire ou principale qui est ce côté
le premier ministre jean castex a dit
hier que l'urgence était aussi à la
mobilisation unitaire beaucoup de
parlementaires ont pu quitter le groupe
la république en marche depuis 2010 est
il avait 314 députés en 2017 il en est
aujourd'hui 275 la priorité c'est aussi
de qui est ce cette unité au sein du
groupe
c'est le l'ensemble des députés la pluie
quand marche s'est constitué ces agrégés
de d'origine politique différente de
certains issus de la société civile
c'est normal qu'au bout de quelques
années après avoir pris ses marques
après avoir travaillé le fond on puisse
se découvrir les tendances plus proche
d'autres groupes et le rejoindre mais
est ce que je remarque c'est que tous
restent d'un dynamique de soutien de la
majorité présidentielle très rapidement
il reste 30 secondes est ce que c'est
plus difficile d'aller à la rencontre
des électeurs avec le contexte de crise
sanitaire actuelle s'efforçant kiffis il
faut prendre des précautions parce qu'on
n'a pas en a paralysé une réunion
publique n'a pas trouvé ça très
responsable d'autant plus que l'or du
temps aurélie les personnes qui nous
soutiennent des cas on voyait des grands
pontes qui viennent s'auto congratuler
et taper sur l'adversaire mais qui au
final propose rarement des choses et qui
ne convainquent personne puisque tous
les clics et des militants préfère les
frapper aux portes
et parler aux gens les marchés dans
merci pierre luc simon dida de la
république en marche dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines pour cette
législative partielle premier tour
dimanche prochain
c'est le 20 septembre et je vous le
disais onze candidats qui sont en lice
dans ce scrutin présentation à présent
de kamal ben marouf qui porte la
candidature sans étiquette république
par raison et pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
être candidat je ce qui m'a convaincu
c'est le traitement ac a achevé de nous
convaincre
c'est le traitement actuel de la
pandémie par l'état c'est ce grand
jacques a dit ce grand emmanuel a dit un
jour ont porté masquer un jour ne
portent pas et de voir que en toile de
fond l'appauvrissement du peuple se
poursuit les libertés individuelles
recul et les divisions soit disant
identitaire s'aggrave
c'est le spectre de la guerre civile
tout cela à mon avis mène à
l'effondrement de la vème république
pour les mêmes raisons pour la quatrième
le régime des partis mais je me demande
si cette fois ci ce n'est pas la
république toute entière qui va y passer
ce sont d'abord des principes il est
possible que le clivage droite gauche et
disparus mais cette disparition ne fait
que révéler un clivage est essentielle
et qui a peut-être de tout temps existé
c'est celui de la compétition entre les
intérêts particuliers
la guerre de tous contre tous contre le
rassemblement le nécessaire
rassemblement pour l'intérêt général
la république indivisible et social
c'est ce rassemblement là que je veux
porter parce que je pense qu'il n'y a
que ça qui puisse nous tirer du péril
dans lequel notre peuple est enfoncée
désormais est là parce que d'abord je
suis un candidat hors parti alors je ne
sais pas si ça fait de moi un meilleur
candidat ou un moins bon candidat chacun
jugera
ça fait de moi un citoyen de la
république qui parle à tous mes
concitoyens mais égaux je veux comme
député pouvoir rassembler tous mes
concitoyens non seulement dans la 11e
circonscription
mais au delà dans la nation et je
voudrais que tous les députés puissent
faire de même pour poursuivre tout
simplement notre histoire commune celle
de notre nation sur le terrain je veux
être un député qui traque tous les
manquements des services publics qui
oeuvrent à une coopération générale
entre les associations
seule véritable alternative à
l'effondrement des institutions c'est à
dire de reconstruire la république par
le bas et à mon avis c'est à cette
condition et cette condition seulement
que la france demeure à notre époque et
j'en suis convaincu et sachez que les
candidats de ce scrutin dans la 11e
circonscription débattront de leurs
idées au cours d'une émission une un
débat pardon à retrouver dès demain à
partir de 20 heures sur tv 78
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité rendez vous dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]